[Music]
all right guys
i have a story of this really cool
building that is actually a waste to
energy power plant
that is also it's the world's largest
waste to energy power plant
and it's also a masterpiece of
architectural design incorporate
incorporating a giant ski slope and a
hiking trail on its roof
and a massive climbing wall on one of
its sides
what is this it's got to be i know it's
[ __ ] sick this isn't in south america
is it dubai
it is not dubai
wait that's real yeah is that india it
currently exists
it currently exists real life you could
go there is it like it becomes a ski
place when it eventually snows no it's a
dry ski
like during the summer months and then
winter months when it's snowing it's
like a snow ski
somewhere where it snows all right
context nope not china
no there what's all those cl what's all
that white stuff is that
steam it's steam so it doesn't it's
zero waste or zero emissions yeah power
plant australia
nope and it is switzerland
is it a scandinavian netherlands uh
sweden norway copenhagen where they're
from denmark
yeah copenhagen i'm like you said
netherlands i'm like is it there i
forgot i can't remember
wait a minute a dutch wow is that
powering it
yeah so this whole thing inside is a
power plant so they get waste from the
entire city
it's like mr fusion i don't know it's my
second back to the future reference
today that [ __ ]
failed on mr fusion it's the part that
uh it's part of the delorean that you
put the trash into
okay that's one of the seconds from your
favorite one from the second oh yeah
but i know what it was called okay yeah
well it's my favorite but i haven't
watched it in a long time
but yeah it's actually in this computer
all three pacific oh really
but anyway yeah so this is like the
longest climbing wall up against i would
have fun with that
this wall scared this wall is here uh
right here
do you guys like rock climbing i do i
haven't really rock climbed that much
well i like the fake one i don't like
real rock climbing i don't know how they
came up with
the real one not the fake one where it's
like that like they have all the
like the bouldering gym yeah the strings
and stuff
no like like when you're inside a
warehouse instead of the mountain
watering is without the harness you like
with the harness though yeah that too
and i don't want to put powder in my
hands and climb my
actual rock that sucks ass absolutely
hated bouldering yeah
you have to put powder though i hated it
well
bouldering is rock climbing without the
harness yeah
you don't go as high i i hated that
what's the difference because
my fingers hurt like it was like too
much like because you can't take a break
yeah i can't take a break exactly you
can actually take a break um
well no you just you kind of rest do you
like kind of a chat there yeah but then
your fingers are still like this and
i just it was too crazy well you like
rock climbing but you don't like
bouldering
because rock climbing you could like
rest because you're still
tethered up i don't have to like still
you're like hey hold it tight down there
oh
geez yeah that's true yeah that's that's
what i want oh
or you could just sit like that and then
like your friends could just pull you up
like this you're just like
yeah you could do that and then but then
the cool thing is that when you're done
rock climbing you could feel like a ci
agent you know
just popping off the side of the
building that's the reason why i like
russell
why don't you just do that there's a
name it's called repelling i think
yeah people just do that they they go
from the top and then
they just repel down but you have to use
your own
strength with that one because you like
hold on to yourself and like let some of
it go let some of it go
this one you have your friend
responsible for you and you're like all
right you better [ __ ] hold me
alone uh i think isaac would like boy
scouts yeah because we repelled every
single summer
so like it's just it's just so fun to be
able to like go down
i would like to do that and then like
it's so comfortable that if like the
adults aren't looking then you go like
this and you let go of the rope and you
and you're facing
straight down and you run down it oh my
god now she's like not going
oh my god no i'm like [ __ ] yeah that's
even more impossible stuff yeah yeah
cause you get really comfortable or you
hang upside down like a spider
like you just get really really like to
be up there like like nelson was saying
you feel like a ca
agent and you like destabilize a third
world country
that's super fun maneuver how um how do
you how do you do that like
is it like connected to a because it's
usually rock climbing it's connected to
um that safety thing or another human
the exact same thing
it's the exact same thing how do you do
it in the wild like
how do you retrieve your [ __ ] you have
to get your own
so that's why they have like those
little spike things so the person that's
the lead climber
has like one of the hardest jobs because
they have to stick it in and make sure
those things go in and it gets wedged in
a rock
do they stay there forever some people
some people will leave it for other
people
stay there forever but because you see
some like welded in and i'm like
how did they get this some of it looks
like a um
like those irons that are in a uh like a
train
like track like it's thick as [ __ ] and
i'm like
how do they get this in the rock so king
arthur's blade like someone's
drilling as they go up i don't know wow
when people boulder upside down like in
those fats
[ __ ] that that's crazy they got toes
that are like fingers yeah yeah
that's just crazy so how much energy
does this thing produce
okay so this [ __ ] just powers one house
capable of converting 440
000 tons of waste into cleaner energy
every year so they burn
trash yes they burn trash so they heat
up like water
trash it's heating up water and with
that heat up water it's able to like
provide energy something i don't know
i'm not interested i do like steam
science yes steam science later so okay
but what about the burned trash smoke oh
um
when they burned the bananas i don't
think they catch it right i don't know
exactly how but they're saying that it's
like
that white stuff is just steam they can
they can probably burn it in a cont like
a contained area where like it goes back
into like something solid and it turns
into dust yeah
charcoal bricks is it kind of like when
someone smokes weed and they blow it up
and they suck it back in at day again
it's exactly like that so it doesn't
really
i think it's like when you smoke weed
and then you blow it into the blanket
and then it doesn't go out it does go
out it still goes out
you smell it so the smoke has to go
somewhere it's like those smoke buddies
yeah how do they do this
the smoke buddies don't work what what's
smoke buddy i've seen it
like when it disappears when they're
blowing what's the smoke
it covers the uh smell of wheat does
this technique with the steam and the
moisture somehow
um con condensate on top and then it
grows the grass and [ __ ] no
so they actually built it trash water
comes down oh but
it does so they did mention that they
put specific
like species of plants at
like the certain altitudes that i can
survive at that altitude
that's right that's better they planned
it really really well let me show you a
video
why are they trying to be all
eco-friendly and [ __ ] because copenhagen
oh oh it's the dot that's why
here we go hey where's his wooden shoes
mr ingalls hands down and you see on his
feet copenhagen
on this uh human-made mountain where you
can hike
uh you can ski what's even more unique
about it oh cool
can you use snowboards to waste two
energy power plant in the world
cleanest waste to energy there are no
toxins coming out of the chimney just
some steam in this case the innovation
is
the clean technology so that meant that
we could completely
re-imagine what does a power plant mean
wow in the city that's crazy you're not
supposed to walk on the grass
you have to wait for the green light you
can't climb the start of the buildings
on this building all the things that
you're normally not supposed to do
you're actually more than welcome to do
why does he sound like sportsnet
at the tallest moment but he's not
austrian there is the tallest climbing
wall i don't know what he is
in the world oh he could be right
elevator that takes you from the foot of
the mountain
i don't know the accent in copenhagen
look out over the city as you rise
danish you can look it up
so even the inside of the plant looks
dumb more than 200 trees
[Music]
all the species have been chosen so they
can endure the climate
almost 100 meters up in the air so it's
this kind of
natural metal it feels
like a little slice of switzerland in
the middle of a copenhagen
it doesn't have to be a dirty polluting
big ugly box that cast shadows on the
neighbors and blocks they've used the
most sort of exciting and dramatic part
in the city is now sitting on a bedrock
of a power plant and the downside is
that it smells like [ __ ]
no that's what i'm worried about that
steams that's like creating trash
fumes no no that's not the burning part
it's like
the the fire is heating up the water and
that's just a steam coming out
it's kind of like when you pass by the
nuclear power plants that's just steam
coming out yeah
it's not like smoke how funny would be
to see a nuclear power plant with a ski
slope on top
and people being like yay
that would be kind of cool that would be
pretty cool better than those like boobs
on the way down to san diego yeah dude
the san onofre they're closed are they
going yeah they're going they're closing
boobs
they decommissioned it already yeah ah
boobs
where's the power gonna come from then i
don't know that's like my landmark on
the way to san diego you know what
we're getting the big boobs why do they
have to make it look like that with a
little nipple on top
they know what they're doing they knew
where they were they knew what they did
everyone calls them the boobs
and they come in they're in pairs too
yeah well it's
yeah there's only two right with nice
cleavage like perfect
yeah and then the ocean in the middle
creating the cleavage because it's right
on the ocean
yeah it's like a girl that was
sunbathing upside down
you know what we talk about this so much
i mean google it because you guys
probably don't know where we're going
san diego everyone's been in california
they know no boobs
you're going to get a lot of just tits
no i popped them really
everyone knows diego boobs san diego
boobies
wait let me get one you can't see the
ocean san diego boom
you click images what happens there's
other boobs oh okay there's other booths
there's all these san diego boobs though
b choice i got bessie in there i don't
want to see you know los angeles these
are the boobies we're talking about see
los angeles moves all the time
but they angled it kind of weird like
you should see it from the other angle
where you see the ocean
when you're driving it's some legit
boost you can see the cleavage when
you're driving yeah it looks like
they're mine
like this
well you know i'm turning 31 soon so
whatever
gravity ain't on your side
[Laughter]
but yeah that's that this building is so
freaking cool
like i wish we had some dope [ __ ] like
that it made me want to try skiing
on grass hey look they look exactly like
those san diego boobs
yeah this is what it looks like these
are actual i wonder where they got the
inspiration from
can you send me that oh i'll send it to
nikki she can give it to you
please don't do that what countries is
denmark uh denmark yeah it also feels
like they're
denmark's like the nerd of the world
though
you know it's almost like like you're in
a classroom and they're like and then
they're like
teacher well i did it this way it was so
easy
and then the rest of the class like you
[ __ ] nerd because i feel like
everyone else is still like we're going
to pollute the world i don't care you
nerd ass denmark
carbon neutral out there right oil is
too lucrative and they call themselves
danes
danes like great beans what do we know
about great danes
oh they're going to die soon yeah they
die in eight years
poor countries they try to extend their
life with like you know zero a lot of
things are expensive there
oh yeah i've been there man copelah i
was in copenhagen it's colder than [ __ ]
when i was there i want to go
there i went to that place the the the
it's very famous they have the
uh colored buildings by side by side
like one's red one's orange one's yellow
oh cool
and there's like a harbor it's pretty it
was pretty cool but it was very cold
and i did not prepare for that oh that's
the one you wear just a hoodie
i was wearing a hoodie until i got a
better jacket yeah
it was rough europe being cold is like a
different kind of cold
i've never been to your pickle it's fun
it's like a chicago cold
it's pretty cool oh chicago was [ __ ]
cold yeah chicago is really cold
it's like if you don't have gloves your
fingers are frozen and if the wind
starts blowing
oh my goodness dang i don't want to go
but it's still fun though i just like
the cold
it makes me feel alive
[Music]
you